>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Larry R. Sarratt:
Good afternoon, everyone.
It is indeed a great pleasure
to be here this afternoon.
My name is Larry R. Sarratt.
I'm the president of the Daniel
AP Murray African American
Cultural Association of
the Library of Congress.
I welcome you on behalf of our
first African-American Librarian
of Congress Dr. Carla Hayden.
And we welcome you to the most
beautiful library in the world.
The Daniel AP Murray Association
of the Library of Congress
and the Motion Picture
Broadcasting
and Recorded Sound Division of
the Library of Congress want
to welcome you to an interview
with the awesome
Russell Williams, II.
We welcome you and hope that
you will enjoy the interview.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Now we will have the
highlight library collections.
Will you all come at this time.
>> Harrison Behl: Hi, everyone.
Everybody can hear me okay?
Okay great.
So, my name is Harrison Behl,
I'm a reference librarian
in the Recorded Sound
Research Center
in the Motion Picture Broadcast
and Recorded Sound Division.
And we're very happy to be
cosponsoring this event today,
and we're excited for
the interview as well.
I thought I would just give you
an little bit of an overview
of our collections, our history,
and some of what we have
available in the recorded sound,
and how it pertains to today.
The recorded sound collections
here at the library are born
out of deposits that were made
to the library starting back
in 1926 with early
78 RPM records.
At that time, recorded sound
was part of the music division,
and then in the seventies,
the record
and sound session was
split out independently
and the collections were
developed on their own.
Sound recordings weren't covered
under copyright until 1972.
But once they were the library
started acquiring additional
copies and our collections
really exploded.
So, since that time,
the library's so on.
Since that time the library is
also been actively collecting
materials that were
produced before then to build
out a representative historical
collection on sound recordings.
And currently we have about 3.5
million items in our holdings.
They're all stored down
at Culpeper, Virginia,
in the National Audiovisual
Conservation Center,
state-of-the-art
preservation facility
with climate controlled,
you know, storage spaces
and also dedicated preservation
staff and processing staff
that take care of
the collections
and make them accessible
to the public.
We do that in a couple
of different ways.
There's dedicated preservation
going on all the time
on large collections
that are prioritized
by our curatorial sections.
That includes the
NBC radio collection,
over 125,000 disks
we received from NBC,
covering from the 1920s
up into the 1970s.
And those are being
preserved all the time
and more are being
made available.
But our preservation is
also dictated by the request
of our patrons and our users,
who come into the Recorded
Sound Research Center,
request materials and we can
get those digitized for them
on demand and access is
provided up here on the hill.
So, we're the access point
for this huge collection
that's being taken care
of down in Virginia.
We have, as you see on the back
table here, we have a display
of some of the formats that are
included in our collections.
Over 120 years' worth
of ideas for how
to capture sound recordings.
From cylinders all the
way up to magnetic tapes,
to the infamous 8-track,
and beyond.
So, take a look back there,
we're happy to answer
any questions about them.
And that's part of what makes
our collection so unique
and challenging is
all the different ways
that we've you know recorded
material and made it available.
I'm sure Mr. Russell's
career spans quite a few
of those different formats
and quite a few challenges
have come up from that as well.
A lot of your material is likely
represented in our collections
through LP releases and
things like that too.
So, yeah, you're well taken
care of here, and with that,
I'll hand it over to my
colleague from Motion Picture.
>> Josie Walters-Johnston:
Hi, everybody,
my name is Josie
Walters-Johnston.
I'm a reference librarian in the
Moving Image Research Center,
which is the sister reading
room to Harrison's reading room.
We are located in the
Madison Building in room 336,
on the third floor,
right across from P&P.
I just wanted to give you
a short introduction again,
to what our reading room does.
As Harrison explained, we are
split to the two reading rooms,
and also the Packard Campus
down in Culpeper, Virginia.
We have over 1.2 million
moving image items,
that cover all sorts of formats.
And along with that, we
probably have another 2 million
like paper documents to support
the research of that film
and television material.
The items in our collections
expands the history of film
and television industry.
From Edison kinetoscopic record
of a sneeze, which was produced
in 1894, to last season's
"Stranger Things."
So, it's kind of like a
lot, a lot of material
that we have in the collection.
But we also have
feature films, newsreels,
educational industrial films,
television news, documentaries,
reality TV program, TV
ads, and much, much more.
As Harrison said
in his statement,
the majority the material that
we get in our collection is
through [inaudible] deposit.
You want to register
material with us,
you need to send us a copy.
But then we also have things
like gift collections,
and things that were
donated to us.
NBC Television news
collection is a huge collection
that we have.
In the back, some of
the display items,
it's actually the first episode
of a series called "Wide,
Wide World" from 1955,
I believe that was.
So, it's kind of an
ornamental cover.
They didn't all come, all
the reels did not come
in gold-plated kind of cover
things, but so we have things
like that in our
collection as well.
Another very large
collection is the NET,
National Educational
Television, PBS collection.
Huge collection.
And actually, on that
note, in terms of material
that is accessible,
that collection is now,
or parts of that
collection can be accessible
through the American
Archive of Public Television.
The cool thing about
that collection,
you do not necessarily have
to physically be here
to get that material.
You can log onto the
website from wherever
and you can watch
PBS programming.
Most of it is going to
probably focus more on,
like local PBS stations,
which is actually pretty cook,
but there are some of the
larger programs as well.
Searching for materials
in our collection,
it means utilizing a bunch
of different resources.
There's the Library of
Congress online catalog
of the MIRC Audiovisual
Information System, Mavis,
which is an inhouse, we
still have a card catalog,
we still love our card catalog.
And we also have finding aids.
Without getting into a lot
of detail on how to do those,
I'd might be happy, if you come
down and visit, give us a call,
we can talk about how
to access that material,
how best to utilize
the resources there.
As I mentioned, the majority of
material is stored in Culpeper.
So, most requests for
reviewing material needs
to be made in advance.
The only exception
to that is anything
that has already been digitized.
If something has been digitized,
we can usually give
it to you on the spot.
Unlike what your experience
might be in Recorded Sound,
which is almost completely
digital,
when you come into listen.
In the Moving Image Research
Center, you might be accessing
like several different
formats on one day.
So, you might have say, coming
in tomorrow, going to start
with my 16-mm film, I'm going
to walk around to the other side
of the viewing room,
going to watch some 35.
Then, I'm going to go
to the other side again,
and watch a laser disc.
Maybe pop in Betamax,
watch a DVD.
Maybe a three-quarter
inch pneumatic tape
and then end my day
watching digital material.
So, we cover all of
those different formats.
And then, in addition to
the moving image themselves,
we also have paper material.
So, we have periodicals,
reference books, subject files,
screenplays, transcripts,
photographs, lobby cards,
press kits, pretty much anything
that will help supplement your
film or television research.
In the back, just to point
out a couple of the examples
and material that
are back there.
The first thing you'll see
is actually a press kit
from "Field of Dreams."
It's actually the press kit and
production notes are inside.
And I already mentioned
there's the NBC TV collection,
the "Wide, Wide World"
premiere episode.
And then, items 3
and 4 are essentially
from the same collection.
Our earliest collection.
It's called the paper
print collection.
That's a portion of it
called the paper print
fragment collection.
So, this is material that was
received before there was a way
to register your
films for copyright.
So, this would be
anything before 1912.
So, those are back
there as well.
And then, on the side,
we both have handouts
that you can take with you.
There is just pamphlet
information
about both reading rooms.
There's how to search, we
have viewing guidelines,
there's some MI; MI?
Moving image resources,
spell it all out.
And then I did take some time
to go through out collection
to see what films and television
programs that we actually have
with Mr. Williams, and we
pretty much have all of them,
except for I would say, I'm
going to estimate, 10 things.
And so, this will include
really early stuff from 1981,
and then all the way through his
unedited history makers there's
like three plus hours oral
history interview, so,
and it's really cool
to listen to.
So, I encourage everyone here
to stop by, come visit us,
pop in just to say hi.
I'd be happy to talk to anybody
about any questions
you may have.
If you're looking for
something specific,
I'd be happy to help you.
Thanks guys.
[ Applause ]
Larry R. Sarratt: Thank
you, Harrison and Josie
for that wonderful
introduction of the collection
that we have in the back.
Here, at the Library of Congress
we have just about anything
that you want to research is
here in these three buildings.
I mean when you say you want to
come to the Library of Congress,
you really need to know which
building you're coming to.
Because we have three buildings
and mostly everybody go
into the most beautiful library
in the world before they come
to the Madison Building, or
either the Adams Building.
So, we have just about anything
you want here at the library.
At this time, we're going
to have our introduction
by Iris Taylor, she's
our treasurer
of the Daniel AP
Murray Association.
[ Applause ]
>> Iris Taylor: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Good afternoon everyone.
>> Good afternoon.
>> And welcome to this
delightful program.
Over a year ago, on Dr.
Martin Luther King's birthday,
I attended a dear
friend's, Dr. Cheryl LaRoche,
annual MLK luncheon celebration.
While there I met an
amazing person named, Joy.
Joya, and we chatted
and of course I talked
about the Library of Congress
and the Daniel AP Murray
African American Association,
and Joya said, "I know
the perfect person to come
to the Library of Congress.
He is down to earth, very
nice, very kind, and so forth."
Then she mentioned the film,
"Glory" I'm thinking
Denzel Washington.
I said, wow.
You never know who you may meet.
I say all that because today,
I have the pleasure and honor
to introduce Mr. Russell
Williams, II who is native
of Southeast Washington DC
and also a former employee
of the Library of Congress.
He received interdisciplinary
bachelor's degree
in film production, art
history and literature
from the American
University in 1974.
Soon after that, he
worked at WRC NBC-TV
as an engineer during the week
and comanaged Spirits Known
and Unknown, a radio
workshop on campus
for minority communication
students that was unique
in the public radio network.
Williams moved to
the Los Angeles,
California area in 1979.
In Los Angeles he built
a reputation for getting
to the oral center of the
scene and preserving it as well
as marry it to the visual.
His career has spanned
live network television
with a list too numerous
to announce.
If you picked it up in
the back, oh my goodness.
Including the Watergate hearing,
radio production, theater,
multitrack recording,
film documentary,
and feature film
sound recordings.
His quest for perfection has
garnered him two Academy Awards
in the category sound
for the movies "Glory"
and "Dances With Wolves."
And two primetime Emmys for
the documentaries "Terrorists
on Trial, the United States
Versus Salim Ajami,"
and "12 angry men."
He is the first African-American
multi-Academy Award winner.
[ Applause ]
Mr. Williams of his many years
of experience in the industry
and apply those blessings
to produce in a career.
He is very passionate about.
He has worked jointly with Isis
Films director Bobby Holland
on videos, commercials and
behind the scenes documentaries.
This seasoned veteran
of the motion picture
world has spent more
than 30 years applying his
trade on all but two continents
and in all 4 of the 50 states.
His credo has been
getting the most
with the least clutter
and confusion.
In 2002, Williams
relocated back to Washington,
DC where he now serves
as a distinguished artist
and residence, and a
professor in the School
of Communication Film
and Media Arts P program
at the American University.
Let's give a resounding applause
to Mr. Russell Williams,
who will be interviewed
by Luis Clavell.
[ Applause ]
Luis Clavell is the
former LCB president
and also he is a member
of the Daniel AP
Murray African-American
Cultural Association.
Mr. Luis Clavell.
[ Applause ]
>> Luis Clavell:
Thank you very much.
This is a great honor to be here
with Professor Russell Williams,
II, and I thank the Daniel
AP Murray African American
Historical Association, Blacks
in Government and the Library
of Congress for this
opportunity.
Let's get right to it.
>> Russell Williams, II:
I just want to apologize
I couldn't get Denzel here
for you today [laughter].
He was busy.
But he sends his love as always.
>> Luis Clavell:
Don't worry prof,
you're looking pretty
good yourself.
>> Russell Williams,
II: Thank you, man.
Thank you.
>> Luis Clavell: Let's
just get right into it
because we had a chance to talk
to one another through the week
and I'm so excited to start.
Let's talk about DC.
Let's talk about Southeast
Washington, DC and your parents,
who I think had a
very fundamental role
to play in your life.
I love the stories
of your mom and dad.
And just to start to
talk about the DC of old.
The old Southeast.
The southeast where kids
were raised by members
of the community
and their parents.
People cared in a certain way
and compassion I think was
there, if I remember correctly.
So, if we could start there.
>> Russell Williams, II:
Well, Luis thank you.
And thank everybody
who came out today.
There's some other distinguished
Southeast residents
and kids in the room.
One I want to point out right
off the top is a retired federal
Judge Gerald B. Lee, who
is a co-manager [applause]
and co-creator of
spirits known and unknown.
And I have a very dear
first cousin sitting
in the front row, Althea.
Would you wave at everyone?
[ Applause ]
Rolled in from Nevada
last night, rolling back
to Nevada this afternoon,
she just wanted to come here
and bring the family love.
I have other family members
here, but Southeast that we grew
up in was a very
tightknit community.
It's not the Southeast
that you typically see
on television today.
Generally, it's bad
news if Southeast shows
up on TV these days and it's
a really unfair portrayal.
Everybody knew everybody
else's kids, Luis, everybody,
all the kids knew
everybody else's parents.
So, just because you went around
the corner and broke a bottle,
or maybe, you know threw a
piece of paper in the middle
of the street, or something
in someone's yard and ran
around the corner assuming
that you had gotten
away with something.
I'm sorry old ma Bell, on
those rotary telephones,
you young people Google
that see what it looks like.
You know, there's no
digital devices back then,
just Google it.
And mom or dad or
somebody would be standing
out on the porch waiting
for you to get back.
Were you at Mr. Clavell's place
and did you break a bottle
in front of his house,
and you know.
So, we knew that
all eyes were on us.
We also knew that
you were penalized
if you disrespected your
elders, you were penalized
if you disrespected
other people's property.
We were also taught that
regardless of one's station
in life from an economic
standpoint, a job, or title,
you had to respect everybody.
And everyone could take a piece
of you if you step out of line.
That's at church,
that's at school.
You know what I'm saying,
that's one of the
neighbors up the street.
I remember distinctly, I think
second grade, I hit somebody
with a spitball, first
thing in the morning.
Okay, boom, teacher
took me out by the hand,
making sure that I
felt pain on the way
to the assistant
principal's office,
this was at Davis
Elementary School, by the way.
Then the assistant
principal took a piece of me,
and then they did the most
horrible thing I could imagine,
they called my mother at home.
And mother, who at that time
wasn't driving had to walk
to school to get her
recalcitrant son.
Walk me back, tuning
me up all the way.
So, that was probably
10;30 in the morning,
so I'm thinking okay I'm done,
right, but here comes about 5:30
or 6, here comes my dad.
And it starts all over again.
I only had one job to do,
that was to get As and Bs,
and if I'm in school
clowning and being disruptive,
that's not the son that he
and his wife wanted to raise.
And even as a high
school student at Wilson,
if I'm standing at the
bus stop on Benning Road,
my old Davis principal would
roll by and say, "Williams,
are you still getting
As and Bs, have you been
in any kind of trouble?
I'm going to check on you.
I'm going to check with
your dad, to make sure."
I mean this seemed like
a lifelong connection,
that was the southeast
that we grew up in.
The people I pointed out and I'm
sure others that are in here.
>> Luis Clavell: Yeah, well
we'd really like to get some
of those qualities back
into the community.
and part of the value
of speaking
with you today is
having a master's class
with a master teacher.
And I think that as we listen,
the young people and people
with children in the
audience, as well as people
that are your age can
reflect on the experience.
Maybe we can get
back to some of that.
Let's talk about say,
high school and Wilson.
I know that you played band
and were talking about sound.
Sound design and a
great within that genre,
so was Bennett Wilson
the first area of sound
that you entered into?
>> Russell Williams, II: Well I
will have to go back a few years
when I was actually
about 10 years old.
I was attending a church in
Northwest with my parents
and for some reason
I want to say
of the choir was
singing spiritual,
the title is 'Hear a Voice a
Praying,' and it was acapella.
And they were in
good form that day.
And I got a little misty
eyed, and some of the elders
who saw me in the
congregation ran to my mom
and said I think Russell's been
called to preach [laughter].
No, but I do want to
take piano lessons.
So, about 10 years old, I
started taking piano and one
of the pictures that's
going by is me standing
between two ladies, one of
those ladies was my first piano
teacher Claretta Proctor.
And that's also a shot
of me right on there now
at a recital that just passed.
So, playing piano
was the first thing
that really made me
a critical listener.
Playing piano also was the
first time that I realized,
I'd heard this whole story about
music can calm the savage beast,
but you know that's stuff
that old folks say to you,
it doesn't really mean anything,
they're just saying
that stuff to you.
Just to get your
out of their face.
So, for some reason, I
can't remember what it was,
I was very upset with my mom
one day, and I said okay,
and she was watching
her soap operas.
I said, I'm going to ruin her
day, I'm going to go downstairs
and start banging on the
piano, so loud that it's going
to interrupt her watching
the soap opera, right?
And I kind of wore myself
out doing that and I said,
well I'm down here, I
might as well do my lesson,
which wasn't anything really
complicated at that point it was
like de, da, de, da, de,
da, de; na, na, de, da, de.
You know it wasn't anything
like Rachmaninoff of Bach
or anything, but literally about
three or four minutes later,
I couldn't remember
what I was angry about.
And so that was the first
time I realized how music can
transport you.
I would blame the 1959
"Ben-Hur," which I saw
as a 7-year-old for
really showing me the power
of music in film.
Because I know I was sitting
next to my parents, and I said,
I don't know what this
movie is going to be about,
but it sounds very important.
But, you know 10 years old
was when I could put my hands
on an instrument
for the first time.
So, that led to going to Wilson
by my Piano teacher's suggesting
to get onto an orchestral
instrument
as well as playing piano.
That's when I really developed
an appreciation for rangers
and composers and
things like that.
And as far as I was concerned,
I was going to be a music major.
And then my master pianist
made the mistake of telling me
about some of his co-eds at
Peabody Conservatory, a couple,
three had jumped out of a window
because they had
failed the final exam.
I said, you know what?
Maybe not, maybe not.
You know, I want to
keep my love as music
as something that's no
pressure involved, you know.
And so, that's when I kind of
started thinking about something
in the communications field by
the time I got to American U.
>> Luis Clavell: Well,
that's interesting,
I can see the less
dangerous approach.
But then, after the piano, I
think you picked up the tuba,
which seems like a dangerous
instrument, back again.
>> Russell Williams, II: Well,
it was dangerous riding
on the Maryland bus.
You all remember the WMA
bus, now that's real DC folks
if you can remember DC Transit.
But then on the other side
of town was this orange kind
of brownish bus called
WMA, which was kind
of like the second
cousin from a bad marriage
in terms of transit systems.
And by that time, I was
at Kramer Junior High,
and Ms. Lockhart, who
was our band director,
orchestra director actually.
Said, oh I'm so happy
that you want to pick
up another instrument,
and she had this room full
of instruments that
nobody was playing
and so she was suggesting
maybe a clarinet,
or maybe a violin or something.
And I'm thinking,
no I don't want
to take another hard instrument.
And is said what's that orphan
in the corner over there.
It was a tuba.
It was kind of bent up, and
it needed some Brasso on it.
So, she said, oh that'd be great
because I don't really
have anybody playing
in the low register.
And I knew already, I could
pick up the tuba parts probably
by Monday, and just sound
the note on the piano,
find it on the tuba,
and you know,
I could already read music.
So, that was a done deal.
Right, except I said okay so
where's the case [laughter].
Oh, there is no case.
Okay, so here's pudgy
Russell on the bus with a tuba
and so you all can go on and
figure out the comedy routines
that spawn from those
trips back and forth.
But anyway, you know, I
weather that as a lot of other,
you know, banter
in southeast, DC.
I mean I think growing up in
southeast made it really easy
to merge into professional
work was when people think
that they've cut you,
they've insulted you,
they said something
that was going
to you know get you
off of your mark.
And I'm like, no, you got to,
you need to go to grad school.
You go to middle
school in southeast,
then you can learn
how to insult people.
This isn't even an
inconvenience, you know.
>> Luis Clavell:
I see your point.
I also remember you talking
about your dad, and the lessons
that you learned from him.
I would imagine at that
time, when you're going
through high school
your relationship
with him was very connected.
Can you talk a little bit
about what he did and what kind
of influence he had on you
>> Russell Williams, II: Well,
you know I'm probably
not unusual in this room,
especially at with my tender
age 30 times 2, plus 5.
Yeah, yeah.
Now, y'all don't rush me.
I'll get there, but
I'm not there yet.
So, I actually, I had two dads.
So, I had Russell
Williams, senior.
And unfortunately, I'd lost
my birth mother the day
after I was born.
So, standing there in the
emergency room was James Harshaw
and my mother's next
oldest sister, Ruth.
And they were childless, and
they made the commitment right
at that moment to say, you
know, we'll raise your son.
Because Russell Williams
is working the night shift
at Union Station as a reg cap.
So, basically, it was tag team.
He was a Taurus, Russell
Williams the first,
James Harshaw was a Taurus, and
I want to say Ruth was a Taurus.
It was actually you know I was
getting it three different ways.
So, James Harshaw was
a master carpenter,
he worked at the
government printing office.
And he also, you know,
like pretty much any other
African American male
or female back then, they had
two or three other side jobs.
He drove a cab, you
know on days off.
He also, because of
being a master carpenter,
he would get together with other
buddies, a next-door neighbor
who couldn't be here today,
her husband was a painter
and down the street
we had a mason,
and around the corner we had
someone who did electrical work.
And they did a lot of
recreational rooms.
You remember those, the you
know the knotty pine walls,
and the drop ceilings
and all of that.
And you know, I'm sawing
wood and doing this kind
of stuff saying, I'm never
going to be a carpenter,
[inaudible] carpenter job.
But, you know, I
learned the trade.
I learned how important
it was to be precise.
it was to make sure
that the customer satisfied.
So, that was that was one of
the lessons from James Harshaw.
And I use that lesson
about learning a trade
later on in life.
Russell Williams, senior
he loved the blues.
His motto or his saying,
regardless of when all the
other voices, my half-sisters
and everybody were
in the room partying,
and discussing the pros
and cons of this, that,
and music artists of this style.
And they would get
all up in arms.
He'd say, look, he said
don't sweat the small stuff.
And so that was, you would
hear him say at least two
or three times a visit,
don't sweat the small stuff.
He was only focused
on the big picture.
So, there weren't too
many folks I could go
to to have a pity party.
You know, Mr. Harshaw would say,
well, you know that's a problem.
But you know what half the
people are glad you have
problems, the other
half don't care,
so which group are you
going to complain to.
That was his way of saying,
you have to work
this out on your own.
>> Luis Clavell: Fantastic.
I want to get back
to some of the things
that Mr. Harshaw told you
before you went to NBC.
Because I think that's
fantastic.
But I think this is
a good point to start
to talk about the library.
Is that okay?
>> Russell Williams,
II: Absolutely.
>> Luis Clavell: All right,
well Professor Williams,
you've been an employee
of the library before.
Could you describe that
experience a little for us.
>> Russell Williams, II:
There's a gentleman who is not
with us today, meaning he's
still on the planet but not
in the room today,
Lowell Vincent Muse.
He was also part of the spirits
known and unknown workshop.
And he was working part-time
here at the Library of Congress.
By this time I was an undergrad
at American U. And he mentioned,
hey, you know, the LOC has these
part-time gigs, I think it was 4
to 8:15 or 8:30, every
day, 5 days a week.
So, you could get your classes
out of the way, come down here
and make some good old
government money, right.
And in my parents'
generation coming
from the Carolinas you know
you had reached the mountaintop
when you have a federal
government job.
All right, you could
basically relax.
And just know that you put your
kids in college, you could buy
that boat that you wanted, or
you know, buy a vacation home
or something, or whatever
you wanted to do it right.
So, I said, great.
I applied for the job, it was in
the stack and reader division,
does that still exist?
No stack and reader anymore?
Okay, all right, but you
know what I'm talking about.
I was handling the PZs.
A lot of the literature
books, right, okay.
Yes, and running over to their
conveyor belt to put, you know,
books down that would
end up in main control.
And as would happen as you
were going down the corridors
of the Jefferson Building
every now and then,
I'd look up at the job
board, and I saw this job
from what was then
called the music division.
And it talked about, well
first of all you need
to understand professional
audio gear, I'm like well yeah,
I'm on the radio,
so that's a start.
A quarter inch tape
recording, yeah I can do that.
Equalization, so on,
and so on, and so on.
And this would be a
fulltime job, you know,
in the preservation of
old materials like you see
in the back of the room.
In our era we were working
with the 16-inch planners from
"Major Bowes Amateur Hour."
I know you've read about
it, but none of the people
in this room have
actually heard Major Bowes,
I mean nobody's that old.
But you can hear
recordings of it,
that's what I was
doing at first at LOC.
And that lasted until
probably the spring of 1973,
when the opportunity to
take a temporary sink
or swim job at Channel
4 came up.
TV engineers are what they
call summer relief engineer.
So, you were working for union
scale, and you would be working
on whatever WRC, NBC
was putting on the air,
but the caveat was
you got a chance
to make three on-air mistakes.
That third mistake ends up
on air, you are a memory.
That means see you,
bye, nothing person.
So, I gave up one delivery.
The second one actually was
because I had trusted Pepco
to keep power on all night,
even during a thunderstorm,
of course, that didn't happen.
So, I was late for
work one time.
I never had that problem again.
And so, I got through
the rest of my summer
without getting to that third.
They had a term for it,
the initials were DS.
So, I got out of there
without that third DS.
But my parents are
very disappointed in me
because I was leaving a
could of been permanent job
for the federal government, to
take a chance on a temporary job
in this crazy TV business.
And I said well, as politely as
I could, I said well understand,
you guys came up from the
cotton fields, one of the things
that you did by coming up from
the cotton fields was give me
the honor of not having to
pick cotton at all except off
of a hanger in the closet.
Also, you've all
given me a platform
that I can hopefully
write my own ticket,
as opposed to just following
completely in your footsteps,
so I said that's what my
mission is is to go further
than you've allowed me to go,
and further than you all
could go in your era,
I've got to push it further.
So, I took the job at NBC, and
that was a successful summer,
but it showed me that I could
make it in show business
and that sounds like a
kind of egotistical remark.
But there was this little thing
called the Watergate Hearings
that was going on in the summer
of '73, and I worked along
with a lot of the other
crew people there,
we worked 22-hour
days 5 days a week.
All right?
So, that means you would
bring some clothes in with you
on Monday and a bar of soap.
You would sleep on a bench
between midnight and 2 a.m.
and 2 a.m. you were
back on the stage,
lighting "The Today Show."
That's when I knew, okay I
can put up with the hours,
I can put up with
live television,
because if you make
a mistake on live TV,
there is no bringing it back.
That era was Barbara Walters as
the cohost of "The Today Show."
And Frank McGee was
the other person.
John Chancellor was
the nightly news guy.
So, that was the era.
And I still had one
year at American U
to finish, but I was like, okay.
As far as I was concerned, it
was going to be broadcast TV.
>> Luis Clavell: Fascinating,
and let's talk more about NBC
and Watergate, because I think
that that's a very
important area.
>> Russell Williams, II:
That's not relevant today.
>> Luis Clavell: I
think it could be.
Could be. Could be the way that
things get lost even in emails,
reminds me of the few minutes
of the phone calls
that were also lost.
So, during the time
that you started at NBC,
I can remember you
telling me a story
of some advice that
you'd gotten.
It started out never
use a hammer
when a screwdriver would do.
And I just wanted you to
kind of like turn the corner
on that story and
let us know about how
that advice really
helped you to get
through another very
interesting situation at NBC.
>> Russell Williams, II: Well,
getting the job NBC
number one was a miracle.
Because I ended up going
to the interview directly
from the Jefferson
Building on my lunch break.
And I was tipped by a young lady
up there named Easter Winters
who is the chief engineer's
executive assistant.
And she called me at work and
said you know the interview
that you had set
up for tomorrow,
by tomorrow all those
jobs will be filled.
Can you come this afternoon?
I was like oh, because I didn't
have a suit on like I have
on now, I had on a nice dashiki.
You young people Google that.
You can see what I'm
talking about, you know.
So, here I am going to
the most conservative
of the then three networks,
if you can imagine
that in a dashiki.
I didn't like my chances.
And I told Easter, well, maybe.
She said, no, no, no.
If you come tomorrow it will be
a purely ceremonial interview.
Today is the thing.
Went up there, met a
gentleman name Mr. Kirkham,
chit chat, chit chat, chit chat.
I tried to just blind him with
my personality and good looks,
so he wouldn't see the
shirt I was wearing.
You know? And you know, told
him all the things I had done,
the Library of Congress, WAMUFM.
I did not have a first class
FCC license, which is one
of the things he wanted.
And we had a good interview,
but now we're on our way
out the door, we're about
to get to the corridor
and I haven't closed the deal.
And just before he gave me
that last little shove back
into the hallway, I
said, oh yeah and how's
that new PCP 90 working out,
which was the then brand new
minicam that RCA had created,
he says, you know
about the PCP 90?
I said yeah, absolutely,
it sounds like,
and this is where I use my
American University education.
I said this sounds
like it's going
to revolutionize
the newsgathering
business [laughter].
I was praying that
something was going
to get through to this guy.
And he said, okay, he said,
well would you like to see it?
I said it's here already?
He takes me back to the shop,
he shows me this camera,
we're sitting there like,
pardon me, two ladies looking
through the maternity room
glass at this brand new camera,
and then he whispers two
words that I'll never forget,
he said well when can you start?
I said well, I'll be
back here at 5 o'clock.
He said, no we'll
call you in two weeks.
So, cut to the story that
Luis is referring to.
So, because it's a union shop,
because it's a seniority shop,
the people that NBC had
at the time in its employ,
that they couldn't be fired
because of their seniority,
but they had some
questionable credentials.
Two or three of these gentlemen
were card carrying clansmen.
Not rumored to be, actually.
And one of those
gentlemen was the supervisor
of projection island, which
is where I was working,
and you know he did a
fair job of telling me how
to turn the projector on
and off, how to thread it
and so forth and so on,
but he wasn't giving
me any real details.
And eventually after three weeks
of trying to appeal to his ego
and other tactics to try to get
him to kind of loosen up on some
of that information
he had stored up here,
one of the black
technical directors,
a gentleman named Carl Bailey,
I think he was the first
black TV TD in the country.
He said, man you don't have to
worry about him, just go back
to the maintenance
shop, get the book,
get the maintenance manual.
I was like yes.
And he said, then
you can come back
on your lunch hour
and you can read.
I said no.
He said no?
I said no, no.
I'm going to bring that
to my workstations.
Yeah, okay bring it
to your workstation.
I said no, but listen
to what I'm saying,
bring it to my workstation,
with his orientation
there's no way he's going
to walk past me seeing
me reading something
and not come check on
what I'm reading, okay.
That's the bait.
And then I took another
piece of my AU education
and brought my little legal
pad with me and a pen.
I knew when he was
coming back from lunch.
I had the book open, I'm
writing my notes down,
I'm being a very good
college student here.
And he comes up over my shoulder
and he asked me was I trying
to get a job in maintenance?
I said, well no, I
said well, you know,
here's something you
don't know about me.
So, I had already set up three
or four code messages
in this reply.
Number one, my dad's
a master carpenter.
So, that means he has a
trade, you have a trade.
The worst whooping, I got from
my dad, I've been disciplined
and you know what discipline
is, you probably handed out some
of yours yourself, am I write,
was then I used a hammer
and a screwdriver to do the
job of a hammer and a chisel.
And my dad said to me, boy,
which code number three, right?
If you can't use my tools in a
proper manner, don't touch them.
I make my living with my tools.
And then I turned to
him and I said sir,
I said these tools back here
are a lot more expensive,
I just want to make sure
I know what I'm doing.
Victory [laugther].
From that point on he showed
me every screw adjustment,
every circuit breaker,
every lubrication point,
how to run the 35-mm projector,
which meant that when he was
out of the building, I was
the only person who'd do
"Meet The Press."
Because at the time, that was
the only national commercial
that Channel 4 only
national commercial
that Channel 4 ran locally.
All the rest of them
would run from New York.
But you know, I try to mention
that story to folks today,
because folks that
you don't agree with,
you don't understand, or
don't agree with there on,
if that is the door
you have to go through,
you have to go through
that door.
So, I said there's got to
be a way I can get this guy
to understand, I'm not here to
pour molasses in the equipment.
I'm not here of spray paint
NAACP over that projector.
I just want to be an NBC
engineer, have a white shirt,
RCA pocket protector,
little air hose
to blow the dust
out of the gate.
And put my 8, or 9, or 12
hours in and collect my check.
Now, he never invited me over
for dinner, but that was okay.
That was okay.
From that summer on,
he basically made sure
if there was any question about
that shop that I needed to ask,
come ask him, because he
knew where everything was.
>> Luis Clavell: Fantastic.
I think there is a
huge secret to success
in what you just told us.
And your life represents
that for us.
So, we are honoring you today
and I'm just really reminded
of that with a story like that.
Is it okay if we get to
1979 and going to LA?
>> Russell Williams, II:
Yeah, let's roll with it.
Let's roll with it.
These people are only getting
older out there listening to me.
>> Luis Clavell: It's
1979, what's going
on with what are you thinking
>> Russell Williams,
II: Well, at that time,
and this is well before Homeland
Security had come along.
There were a lot more
feature film shooting in DC,
at least portions of them, one
of them I remember seeing is
"Being There" with
Peter Sellers.
I just saw Peters Sellers
walking down 14th Street
and some other locations.
And so, by this time, I had
also worked at Channel 7, local,
which was shooting news on film.
And so, that was my first
professional experience working
with film.
So, I said you know,
maybe it's time to think
about taking the Neste plunge
and going to Los Angeles to see
if I could get into
big show business.
From "Ben Hur," I recognized
that sometimes you don't
recognize the miracles
that are right in front of
you, but miracles still exist.
So, in the same pile of mail
that I got a no thank you
from AFI, when I applied
to their directing program,
good old Uncle Sam gave me
a nice income tax return.
I said, you know what, there's
more than one way to get to LA.
So, there was this airline
back then, called TWA.
You all Google it, you
young folks, Google it.
I had planned to go to LA, and
I took a 90-day leave of absence
from WMAL radio, which
was my permanent job
at the time, to try LA.
I was also headed down the
aisle in September of that year.
And I had wedding plans already
in place, deposits had been put
down on a rehearsal hall
or something like that,
why are you laughing, Sam?
I'm trying to tell a story over
here and you're interrupting me.
And as things do happen in
your life from time to time,
at the time, the betrothed
and I were both going to LA,
because she was working
here for WETA
and planned to go to KCET in LA.
And of course, I was just going
to go to anybody out there
that would get me a paycheck.
And then at the last minute
or she decided she
didn't think she could be
that far away from her folks.
So, maybe we could get
married, but then maybe wait
until the next year
to go out to LA.
And I was like, I'm certainly
not liking the sound of that.
Especially since I'm already
unemployed for 90 days.
There is no going back on that
you know leave of absence,
they've already hired
somebody else to cover me.
So, I said well, you know what
think about it, and let me know,
but I said, my future,
somehow I see LA in my future.
And so, she didn't move on
her position, so I said,
well I think we're going to
have to tell your parents,
we're not getting married.
Well, why aren't we getting?
Well, you want to; I mean
how are we doing this?
So, as it turned out I
had to go to Baltimore
in her parents' kitchen and
very wisely tell her parents,
well I didn't deserve a woman
as wonderful as their daughter.
And I didn't go in and say
that she was just a coward,
and just didn't want
to take that next step.
That wouldn't have been smart,
that were so many butcher
knives, and other you know,
things that could
have been projectiles
in the room, you know.
So, we got through that and
we were all cool after that.
But that's when I realized
that I was laser
focused on this career.
And as it turned out,
had I waited a year,
just so you all can jump
to the next chapter,
had I waited a year, then
that would have been right
at the beginning of the
Screen Actors Guild strike,
which shut Los Angeles
down for months.
I couldn't have even gotten
arrested, and we're talking
about LAPD, I couldn't have
even gotten arrested out there.
So, timing is everything.
And so, I went at the
right time, it worked out.
I guess, otherwise,
Luis wouldn't have me
up here boring you
with all these stories.
>> Luis Clavell: Well, I'm glad
you selected your words properly
for the young lady's family.
>> Russell Williams,
II: Oh yeah,
I mean you know I was like,
oh you know I might need
this neck some other time.
>> Luis Clavell: Well,
great you still have it.
What did a break look like
for you once you were in LA?
What did that moment look
like when you said, well yeah,
I'm on the right track now.
>> Russell Williams, II: Luis,
that's a loaded question.
First job off the plane, now
I want to see a show of hands
and you young people don't
even bother to answer,
because I know you're
not up to this.
Who's ever heard
of Rudy Ray Moore?
Okay, I don't see anybody with
a full head of hear [laughter].
Okay, Rudy Ray, the actual
first person I worked for in LA
at the Dunbar Hotel
on Central Avenue
where he was living
in the basement.
And just to show you that
I could remain optimistic.
I mean because he
was a nice cat,
don't get me wrong,
really nice guy.
But his jokes were
you know, yeah.
So, basically when I
realized that I may,
have I made the right decision,
one of the first
jokes I recorded
that he said was how do you keep
the flies out of your kitchen?
Well, it's real simple,
you keep the bucket
of in the living room.
And so, immediately
I started [laughter].
You know, and one
of my assistants was
like what are you doing?
I said, well I'm just trying
to make sure this is
the actual bottom.
That there's no other
level below this,
so I can only go up from here.
So, that was the
actual first job.
And then, if you got a job,
it was three or four days
in a row, okay that's great.
Two weeks in a row,
okay that's great.
It took me seven years to get
into the labor union out there,
which is not the same
issue as it would be today,
because the rules have changed.
And I worked for a lot
of different people,
a lot of low-budget
producers and directors.
I would say one of the
first big brakes I got was
through a director
named Alan Meyerson
who I had worked
another 2 or 3 days,
22 hour days for flat $100.
And like a lot of people out
there will tell you, kid,
you know when I get
some real money,
I'm going to call
you again, you know.
How many times, if
you had a quarter
for every time somebody told
you that, you'd be staring
down at Bill Gates saying, see?
See? But he did call.
And that job turned
out to be five months
of work, and I was like ah.
I bought a new van,
bought a lot of new gear.
You know, I was respectable all
of the sudden, I started looking
at housing prices, you know.
But it's really one job at
a time, and it's really,
my first three years were more
like, they weren't calling me.
They were calling the
person that they knew,
and the person they knew
may have been busy and said,
you know what there's
this new kid
out here named Russell Williams,
he'll do a good job for you.
Give him a shot.
So, it was three years before
anybody was actually calling
me directly.
They were calling Luis,
because they already knew Luis.
And you have to understand
regardless of gender, age,
religious preference,
ethnicity, the scariest thing
in a highly competitive
field is someone
who is an unknown quantity.
And once you find a team
that works together well,
you probably, you know the
whole Yankees that we all hated
when we were outside
of New York,
the reason that they
stayed the old Yankees
because they very rarely
took on any new talent.
Because they had Murderers'
Row and all those other folks.
So, to get into that
league, you could have been
in the major league baseball,
but you weren't going
to be the Yankees
unless you were the best.
So, that's how most people
think of their careers
in the entertainment
industry and other fields
that are highly competitive.
That's what makes it
so hard to break in,
in addition to whatever else
they may bring with them.
>> Luis Clavell: Well baseball,
will lead us right into "Field
of Dreams" then right?
So, I guess that was
a pretty decent break.
>> Russell Williams,
II: That was the,
I mean of the low budget, no
budget films that I did leading
up to that, that
was the first film,
when I read the script I said,
not only is this a great script.
And then as the casting started
to fall into place, I'm like,
wow, I'm going to be working
with great actors too.
And I'd already worked
with the director.
That's one of the places
I learned loyalty, Luis.
Was the only reason that "Field
of Dreams" was offered to me,
the director Phil
Alden Robinson,
who was also the screenwriter,
which he was much more
comfortable doing,
is working as a screenwriter.
He told Gordon brothers, now
you all may not know the Gordon
brothers, but you
know the franchise
that made them rich was a
franchise called "Die Hard."
And that was 1988 as well.
So, I must have seen "Die
Hard" 1 at least 6 or 7 times
in Dubuque, Iowa, because what
other movies were going to come
to Dubuque, okay at
that particular summer.
Phil told them that the only way
that he would consider directing
"Field of Dreams" was if he
could bring all the people
from his first movie, which did
you know, marginal business,
but they were impressed
enough with it
to give him that particular job.
And they said, yes, if that's
what it's going to take for you
to call action and cut.
So, bring all his people
back into "Field of Dreams,"
also essentially, got me
"Dancing With Wolves,"
because that was the first time
I worked with Kevin Costner.
And Kevin did a similar thing.
He took people from different
movies that he had worked
with that he liked
and broth them
to his directorial debut
out in South Dakota.
But I was really like
honored to work with people
like James Earl Jones, to meet
Kevin who was a really cool guy.
But, from going to the movies
with my mom and dad for many,
many years, I'm sitting
there behind the console,
and I'm looking at this guy
with this gleam in his eye,
and his jaw, and I'm like
man that's Burt Lancaster.
I mean, I'm working
with Burt Lancaster?
And that's probably the only
time that I've been on a set,
because we don't have
the benefit of the music
and whatever visual
effect that you'll see
in the finished product, but
when Burt Lancaster walks
across that first baseline to
become the doctor and attend
to Kevin Costner's little
girl, I have tears in my eyes,
and I'm thinking; I say wait
a minute, wait a minute.
What the heck is wrong with
me, I said this is not a play,
you know what I'm saying?
But I mean he was
just that good.
You know, and I really
thought that all those years
of not knowing whether this move
to LA was going to really be
for anything, I said, okay.
And I think the first
week I was there,
or first month I was there,
I said this is going
to take 10 years.
So, this was basically 9
years into that 10-year plan.
And one of the other things
that I realized leading up to
that was, and I will
tell this to everybody,
that don't discount the
nay-sayers that creep up on you.
Sometimes it might even be
your parents, or besties.
You know, somebody, your
coworkers, and you have
that dream and you
want to like go out
and do something,
and they're like ah.
And you know, they may have
the best of intentions.
A lot of those guys I worked
with at WMAL radio said man,
you're a fool if you
think you're going
to get any work in Los Angeles.
Okay, well I'm that
kind of fool.
I got 90 days to find out
[laughter] whether your version
of me is right, or my
version of me is right.
But the nay-sayers
are important,
because if they can talk you
out of pursuing your dream,
you weren't going
to do it anyway.
Let me repeat that, you
weren't going to do it anyway.
Because even if everything
works out fine,
there's still going
to be resistance.
You still have to be the best,
which means that you've got
to put in the extra hours,
you've got to be competitive,
you've got to do all this new
work to learn this new field.
So, that's with nothing
else interfering with that.
And of course, when
I went to LA in '79,
it was not an original idea.
So, there's a long line of
people that get off the plane
at LAX thinking they're going
to do something in showbusiness.
So, just look at that
line, and say okay well,
be here for a little while,
but that's how we vet you,
that's how we get
rid of the people
who are really not serious.
You know, if you get a
law degree, you still have
to pass the bar before
you can practice.
So, that's a vetting process.
You get a medical degree,
you have to pass the state
boards before you can start
chopping people up,
that's a vetting process.
But you have a grad degree in
film, or you know, television
or radio, and okay, so,
all right, see that corner
on the far end of the
room, 18 hours you'll be
in that corner making sure
nobody walks into the shot
for $100 a day flat, a tuna fish
sandwich and a glass of lemonade
and three or four weeks later,
if you're still smiling,
that's an indication
that you're serious
about being in this business.
All other people
run out of breath,
and mad that's not what I had in
mind, or I thought I was going
to come in and there was going
to be a red carpet there.
Well, yeah, maybe is Halle Berry
was on the same flight with you,
but that's how we vet you.
So, don't run out
of breath too soon,
it's going to be
a long marathon.
>> Luis Clavell: Understood.
And your long-term planning is
really added in in everything
that you're saying, prof.
Well, let's talk more
about being the best,
and the academy.
>> Russell Williams, II: What,
did Denzel come in [laugther]?
Oh, oh, you're talking about me?
>> Luis Clavell: Yeah, we've got
a certain version of that here
with us today as
a matter of fact.
So, you have the two Oscars,
you've got the two Grammys.
>> Russell Williams, II: Emmys.
>> Luis Clavell: Emmys.
>> Russell Williams, II: I'm
working on Grammys as soon
as I learn how to sing.
>> Luis Clavell: So, Oscars
Emmys and you're a member of the
>> Russell Williams,
II: That's correct.
>> Luis Clavell: So that's some
phenomenal areas to talk about.
Of course, last year the
Academy basically tried
more inclusiveness.
>> Russell Williams, II: Right.
>> Luis Clavell: We heard things
from when Chris Rock was host
that brought us to
a greater awareness
of what was going
on in the Academy.
Let's talk about
what that means.
And you know, I'm going to
just set you loose on it,
because you know, I want to make
sure we get around to a couple
of other things, especially
the questions at the end.
So, the other thing that I was
hoping that you would touch base
on was that the Motion
Picture Academy's Museum is
opening soon.
And of course, they
are thinking about ways
to represent minority
contributions.
So, with all that said,
what can you tell us
about the standards
of excellence.
>> Russell Williams, II: Okay.
Well, with hashtag oscarsowhite
happening I think two years
in a row, that really,
Cheryl Boone Isaacs
who was the first
African American woman
to be the Academy president,
and she had been on the board
of governors for, I think
easily 15 to 20 years.
She came into the
business almost at the top.
She came in in the PR realm,
and the first movie she got
to work on, no like me,
was "Close Encounters."
That's how she came
into the business.
So, she saw the hashtag.
She heard the outcry.
But let's talk about why the
Academy looks like it does.
First of all, the
film business started
in the Jim Crow era
in the United States.
So, it was very difficult for
anybody with a permanent tan
to get on the set to
build a career long enough
that you could be
invited or be nominated
for one of the two statues.
There's only two ways
to get into the Academy,
that have to be nominated
for an Oscar, or two people
in the branch that you're
representing, be it camera,
sound, costume, acting,
directing.
Two people from those branches
have to send a letter saying,
you know what, we want
to consider Roselyn
Williams as a new member.
And the membership
committee of that branch.
There's 17 branches.
Each one of those branches
has a different set of rules.
So, imagine my surprise on,
I think it was March 26th,
of 1990 that not only was I
nominated and won the Oscar,
but then they said, but I'm
not automatically invited
into the Academy yet.
And that's when, southeast
DC came out of my mouth,
and I said now wait a minute is
that the black rule,
or is that the rule?
And they said, no, no,
no it's in the rule book.
And I said what's
the rule book say.
So, in other words, you
needed 8 years of credits
to be considered,
in addition to,
and that's still
on the rule book.
So, sound, for some reason
has the longest requirement
of experience of any
of the other branches.
If you're in the acting
branch, just the fact
that you got nominated,
generally is enough
to get an invite.
So, that's one.
But now, let's put this
in the realm of sports,
because I think it's a lot
easier for people to understand
that the Academies, plural,
meaning Music Academy,
Television Academy,
Motion Picture Academy,
what they really do
is keep people out.
That's what they really do.
Okay, the same way the Hall of
Fame doesn't accept everybody,
be it football, or baseball,
who's played the sport.
Okay, even someone
like Karl Malone
who had 18 great seasons playing
basketball, he never got a ring.
But we can accept
that in sports.
Because, one, we know the score,
we know all the statistics.
And most of that
process is transparent.
We don't really see
the Academy's process.
I don't know whether
"Glory" won by 1 vote,
or 10 votes, or 1000 votes.
So, I'm fairly sure that
process will remain opaque,
and so people don't trust it
because they don't
know what's going on,
if anything, behind the scenes.
I would also say that the whole
concept of it being difficult
to win an Oscar, Emmy or
Grammy is going to remain.
You know, they're not handing
them out at Home Depot,
or at Starbuck's when you
get that extra tall latte.
It's supposed to be a
hurdle that you jump over.
So, that makes people upset
because they're thinking,
well how did this film not get
recognized, da, da, da, da, da.
It's a lot of that is math.
Okay. If there were 350
or so movies this year
that were eligible for Oscar
nomination, let's say each one
of those movies had at
least 10 actors in it, okay.
And of course some of
these actors appear in more
than one movie per year,
but you're talking more
than 3000 roles, which
have to be whittled
down to only 20 nominations.
So, best, best, and
supporting, supporting.
So, it's almost as
bad as thinking
that Powerball is a
sure thing [laughter].
Okay, and I can think of
a lot of actors that are
in the so-called tribe
that didn't win Oscars.
Directors like Hitchcock
never won an Oscar.
You know what I'm saying.
So, a lot of times,
we may look at it
as this is directed
towards people of color,
but what it really is, is that
mathematically it's difficult,
and then, because of the way the
membership looked at the time,
maybe it was going to be
more difficult for you
to determine whether, say
Don Cheadle's role in "Devil
In a Blue Dress" was
him in character,
or that was just Don Cheadle.
See, now we know Don Cheadle's
got a whole lot of range.
But at the time, you know,
I think some people
were kind of befuddled.
Is that kid really that
good, or is that just him?
So, with the real push to
diversify, and also add a lot
of younger members,
the Academy is hoping
that the representation
in the nomination
which has been fairly good
this year will continue
to go in that direction.
But say, in my branch, I can
say with almost 100% surety,
there are only five African
Americans in the sound branch,
and maybe 6 people
of Hispanic descent,
of a branch that's
about 450 people.
Okay, so part of that
is that what do we want
to do in the business.
Do we want to do sound, or do we
want to act, direct, you know?
So, if no one is pursuing
a career in sound,
then that can't be
blamed on the Academy.
If I wanted to blame somebody,
I might maybe drop
the Image Awards,
because the Image Awards very
rarely highlights people's
accomplishments behind camera,
so that kids like me trying
to figure out what to do in
showbusiness would know, oh,
wow, I could be a
cinematographer.
Okay, because you know, nobody's
going to hire me as an actor.
Or, oh, maybe I could be
a production designer.
Or maybe I could
do visual effects.
And the only reason that I ended
up even considering African
Americans working behind camera,
was because in 1967 when
I went to see "In the Heat
of the Night" on the big screen
for the sixth or seventh time,
I said wait a minute,
wait a minute,
I said Quincy Jones
did the score.
I said, so what the African
Americans are working
behind camera?
Now, in front of the
camera, that was no headline,
we had been there
since the silence.
But, behind camera in an
important role like that,
I said okay, note to self.
Now, it didn't mean
that I immediately started
packing my bags, you know in '67
and started working towards LA.
But, at least I knew
the seed was there,
I knew it was possible.
And so, when I did get a
chance to shake Quincy's hand,
many years later I
told him I blamed him,
I said you're the
reason I'm out here.
I just want you to know that.
You're the reason I even
put that up, you know,
that thought in the air.
So, that I think is a little
bit about the Academy.
But you all are free
to try your hand at it.
I'll help you with
your acceptance speech.
And I'll point you to people in
your field who can mentor you,
because that's very important.
And you can go on
and get your own.
Because I'm tired of being only
one of three African Americans
that have multiple Oscars.
We need a whole lot more folks
in that crowd [applause].
>> Luis Clavell:
Absolutely, well said, sir.
I know that we're kind
of rounding the corner
on our time together, but I know
that some nominees
came out last night.
"Shape of Water," and "Get
Out" which one is going to win?
>> Russell Williams, II:
Oh, for best picture?
I'm fairly, fairly confident
that "Shape of Water"
because not that "Get
Out" isn't an impressive,
not only directorial debut,
but it just changed the whole
conversation in the room.
But I want to say that
"Shape of Water" I think,
by and large is the
kind of movie
that has Oscar bait
written all over it okay.
One movie for sure
that I was disappointed
that did not hit the best
picture nine, because we have
up to 10, and I said so what
happened with that tenth one?
It could have been "Mudbound"
which I thought was very
well directed, very nuance.
Beautifully shot.
The first woman to ever be
nominated for cinematography.
After all these years,
I mean the first woman I met
doing cinematography I met here
in DC in '78, was a lady
named Karen Grossman
who was here in town from LA.
And I'm thinking, you know.
But, Dee Rees, who directed
"Mudbound" also got nominated,
I want to say for adaptive
screenplay, co-nominee.
"Get Out" I think
is going to do well.
but I'm kind of thinking
at this moment,
"The Shape of Water" is going
to be the film this year
in terms of best picture.
And that's one thing I wanted
to mention before we move
on to the Q&A is
that in the branch,
I can only nominate in sound.
If my wife was in
directing branch,
she could only nominate
for directors.
If my cousin, here, was in the
production designer's branch,
she could only nominate
for production design.
But then, we all get to
nominate for best picture.
So, that's why best
picture nomination is really
to me more representative
of the actual academy
than the actual branch
nominations, which could be kind
of more insider trading.
>> Luis Clavell: Well,
thank you very much,
Professor Russell Williams, II.
I'd like to thank you on
behalf of everyone here,
Danial AP Murray African
American Historical Association,
all of the library
employees that have benefited
from you being here so early.
People like me can now walk
through the halls
quite confidently.
I also would like to ask
you, what's next for you?
And then we'll open it up for
the questions and answers.
>> Russell Williams, II: Well,
let's see, I've been teaching
at American for 15 years.
And I really have enjoyed trying
to mentor some of
the new talent.
I have some AU students and
former students in the room,
could I see some hands.
Oh, baby.
[ Applause ]
Now, not all of these students
in the room got A's
from me [laughter].
But the fact that they
understood that I was saying,
okay bring your game
up a little bit more,
I'll make that phone
call for you,
means that I hopefully
did something right.
I'm still very much
interested in big show business.
So, anything above the line now.
Above the line, below the line.
Below the line means
the creative labor.
Sound, camera, wardrobe,
makeup and hair.
But above the line is
writing, producing, directing,
and sometimes your
top-flight cast.
I'm always looking
for opportunities
and things in that realm.
You know?
My wife and I want to have
a house in the Vineyard,
we want to have another
house in Palm Desert.
So, it may be hard to accomplish
that on an academician salary.
But, I'm always looking
for opportunities
to bring the younger generation
in and turn them loose.
But I can only do that
if they understand naval
observatory time.
That's lesson number one.
>> Thank you.
Thank you.
>> Luis Clavell: Absolutely,
well thank you very much, sir.
>> Russell Williams,
II: Thank you, Luis.
Ladies and gentlemen, the 2018
Trailblazer Legend Award winner.
Professor Russel Williams, II.
[ Applause ]
>> Darren Jones: Good afternoon,
everybody, I'm Darren Jones,
the program director for
the Murray Association.
In the interest of time,
we're going to be able
to take two questions,
because we don't often,
in fact we've never had a
two-time Academy award winner
accept our invitation
and come here.
And we are on a time schedule.
We want all of you, if you have
an opportunity to grab a bad
in the back as you leave
out, but we also want you
to take a picture with Mr.
Williams, if you so choose.
So, if there are any questions,
we're going to be able
to take two, and then
we're going to move
on to our award presentation.
Right here in the front.
>> Melvin Whitten:
Great think you so much,
my name I Melvin Whitten,
I'm an entertainment lawyer
and we're really good friends,
but what I wanted to ask you was
at Howard University
School of Law we had a motto
that was called lifting
as we climb.
So, as you climb, you know,
how do you lift and reach back
and bring others forward.
>> Russell Williams, II:
Thank you, Mel, good question.
At our spirits known and unknown
workshop which started in 1971,
our motto was each
one teach one.
And that motto has served
me well, my cofounder,
Gerald Bruce Lee and hopefully
all the people who have come
through that workshop.
And even when I was working
in the industry, you know,
I would look for people who were
interested in what I was doing
or if they weren't interested in
what I was doing specifically,
to point them to the
people that can mentor them.
But at the same time, I
was also vetting them.
You know, something
like Sergeant Waters
and "A Soldier's Story" it's
like okay, we're not looking
for a bunch of fooli9shness,
because it's image
is everything.
All right, and especially in
the time I started working
in the business, I had a couple
directors say, man, you know,
he said your crew's all black.
I said yeah.
He said, well that's
kind of unusual isn't it?
I said, well, I thought my crew
should reflect the department
head like everybody else's crew.
And he said, oh yeah,
yeah, you know [laugther].
You know what I'm saying.
So, I mean you have to try
to give them a little truth
and not make it assaulty.
But you know to me, Mel,
it's always been important,
because trust me,
there's no way that I'm
on this stage telling
my story except
for people giving
me the opportunity
to come through the door.
And people taking a
chance on me Paul Kirkham,
Paul Fime who was at ABC.
This guy named Bill Cooper
took me under his wing
when I came out to LA.
And that's another thing,
if you haven't figured
this out already.
All your mentors may
not look just like you.
Okay, but if someone's
willing to take the time
to show you what
made them successful,
or even if they were an abject
failure, show you how not to go
down the road that they went
down, which is very important.
If I see another
movie of someone going
through the do not
enter bridge out,
went over the bridge,
went over the cliff.
Crash the car, then
they crawl back
up on their fingernails
to the road.
It's like no, no can't we have
a movie where it shows you how
to recognize the signs
before you go over the cliff.
That's the movies I want to see.
Next question.
>> Yeah, this is a
pretty quick question.
Russell and I go back many,
many years and a third friend
who goes back with us as well.
I started a production company
some years ago and picked
up the phone and called the two
of them and they got on a plane,
and we did the 25th
year anniversary
of the Congressional
Black Caucus.
From Bill Cosby to Gladys Knight
and whoever else were all in it.
And I only had the
nerve to take savings
and buy cameras and equipment.
They had the nerve to trust
in me and come to do that.
So, this is a lesson to all of
you students that are in here.
I was a student in
that business.
And this man, really
made a difference for me.
So, I've actually had a
company, and then sold one.
So, I'm only saying that to
you, to let you really realize
that maybe you didn't get an
A in the class [laughter].
I did. Follow the lead.
He's there for you.
>> Darren Jones: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Now we're going to
have a presentation
of our highest award.
We have our vice
president, Ahmed Johnson.
And Ahmed is the African
American history specialist
and local history and genealogy
here at the Library of Congress.
>> Ahmed Johnson:
Thank you, Darren.
Once again, my name
is Ahmed Johnson.
Thank you, thank you.
And on behalf of the Daniel AP
Murray African American Cultural
Association we'd like to present
you with this gorgeous award.
Trailblazer for 2018.
Thank you, sir.
[ Applause ]
And we have other gifts.
You never come to the
Library of Congress
and not get a book, right?
We have "Black Americans in
Congress from 1870 to 2017" one
for you and one for your wife.
>> Russell Williams,
II: Oh, thank you.
[ Applause ]
While means I'm going to
carry both of them [laugther].
>> Ahmed Johnson: Once again,
we thank you for coming
and what a wonderful program.
Thank you.
>> Darren Johnson: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Thank you, sir.
I want to also thank
you all for coming.
We have grab bags in the back.
The Murray Association is
an association of a Library
of Congress that
was found about one
of our leaders here
at the library.
We do have applications
in the back.
Anybody who's interested
in African-American
culture and history.
We would hope that
you would join.
It's $5 a year.
You will get emails
to let you know
of the programs we're
having and also if you want
to become a life
member it's $100.
So, we do have some
life members.
So, see Theresa Davis in the
back, raise your hand Theresa,
to get an application, fill
it out, leave us a check,
or some money and we
will get you on the list.
We have grab bags int eh back
and we also want you to look
at the exhibit we
have in the bac.
>> Iris Taylor: Also,
you can take pictures
with Mr. Williams outside.
We have a red-carpet area that
you can get selfies with him.
>> Darren Johnson: And thank
you for coming, everybody.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.